et alors que les discussions entre
sénateurs et députés autour du pass
vaccinale ont donc échoué certains
voient dans la gestion de la crise
sanitaire par le gouvernement une
manoeuvre politique écoutez à ce propos
gilles casanova expert en stratégie et
communication
nous ne sommes pas dans du médical nous
ne sommes pas dans du sanitaire on ne
pense pas à la santé des français on est
dans du pur politique et même du
politicien puisque nous avons d'un côté
une vague dont le ministre de la santé
lui-même positif aux cabines d'ailleurs
maintenant indique qu'elle pourrait être
la dernière étant donné que nous avons
des centaines de millier de
contaminations chaque jour que nous
avons des millions de cas contact chaque
jour nous avons donc les conditions pour
que se crée une immunité collective nous
avons 90 % de vacciner par ailleurs donc
nous sommes dans une phase de sortie de
la phase épidémique
nous sommes dans une phase où au
contraire il s'agit d'organiser cette
sortie et nous avons un exécutif qui au
contraire replongent le pays dans des
contraintes extrêmement forte que rien
ne justifie si ce n'est une volonté
politicienne d'empêcher le débat de la
présidentielle sur les sujets de la
présidentielle